well when you're recording YouTube
videos it is critical that you know how
to create videos that will give views
and subscribers and really help you make
an impact in the world and I am so
excited to bring you today's episode
where we share with you one of the
sessions from our recent seven-day
YouTube influence challenge and in this
session I'm going to be walking you
through step by step are think media
YouTube framework how do we actually
make videos and some of this mistakes
that you might be making right now in
creating videos that you don't even know
you're making and how to change them
coming up welcome to the marketing
podcast the number one podcast for
growing and scaling your business with
online video i'm heather torres and i'm
shawn kennel and we're from think media
and if this is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content notice and the latest
money-making strategies working right
now online so whether you want to grow
your YouTube channel or you want to
maximize video across all of social
media this podcast is for you now Before
we jump into the session I just want to
tee it up a little bit for you you are
about to listen to one of the sessions
that we had inside of our 7-day YouTube
influencer challenge and we were walking
through the seven step framework that we
teach here at think media and I think
marketing and this is our signature
proprietary process that is inside of
our premiere course video ranking
Academy where we teach you our proven
step-by-step system this seven step
framework throughout the entire course
and so we are bringing you one of those
lessons which is the record part of the
seven step framework this is the third
part of the framework and you'll hear
more about that as we are walking
through this session but I just wanted
you to know that this is one of those
sessions where you want to lean in this
is where I'm walking you through what
needs to make sure our inside of videos
like when you see videos that are really
winning on YouTube they have these
ingredients and really making a video on
YouTube is like using ingredients to
make a cake and I'll walk you through
little bit more about that but I just
wanted you to know that we are excited
to be bringing you these types of these
pieces of content that we've had
throughout our different training
sessions and we would love to know your
feedback on social media by using the
hashtag think marketing if you take a
screenshot and let me know do you like
hearing these type of sessions and I
can't wait for you to dive in so grab
your notebook or if you're out on a run
or cooking dinner
just just be baking some mental notes
and I'm excited for you to listen to
this session from our recent seven-day
youtube influence challenge and in this
session today we're gonna be covering
the think media content formula three
ways to make your YouTube videos better
and the mistake that you might be making
when you start your videos and what to
do instead and you know when I think
about creating videos you know I shared
my story yesterday that um for four
years ago five years ago I never thought
I'd be creating videos I never thought
I'd be going live once a week to do
trainings and coaching I never thought
that this was what I was gonna do but
understanding the skills understanding
that video is the medium is the vehicle
to be able to get my message out to the
world I had to just jump in and learn
how to do it and you know it reminds me
of really um it reminds me of making a
cake you know when you're doing video it
really is about putting the right
ingredients in the cake you know I love
cake let me know in the comments what's
your favorite do you like chocolate do
you like vanilla do you like what's that
other one
funfetti you know what the funfetti cake
you like funfetti cake tell me what your
favorite cake is I unfortunately can't
have dairy and this is not at all what
you needed to know so we'll move on but
I normally can't eat these kind of
delicious cakes but I digress let's move
on alright so making a cake requires the
proper ingredients it requires the
proper ingredients and it requires skill
you know when I make a cake it does not
look great it doesn't come out like this
you know this is a beautiful unicorn
cake we we got a cake just like this for
my daughter when she turned eight years
old she was obsessed with unicorns and
so he
did a beautiful unicorn cake but if I
were to make the cake it would look
something like this yes have you have
you seen these cakes before you know the
fails they've got that TV show nailed it
well this is what happens a lot of times
when people are making videos they see
other content creators like Casey nice
sad and Sean can all to think media team
and beauty inspiration YouTube channels
their gardening I mean they see all
these people who are professionals
making video and when they do it it
turns out like this and that's because
there's a formula to creating great
videos and Tony just shared a really
great tip which was that you should be
putting b-roll into your videos so that
you can be more of a storyteller through
a very simple educational video and
remember we talked about this before
prior planning prevents poor performance
but you know a lot of times it's not
necessarily like well I don't really
understand the things of the videos and
now we've gotten over our fears and we
know that we need to just crush them we
need to start we need to go all-in
maybe you've been creating videos for
awhile and you're just like I just can't
figure this thing out and a lot of times
when people are starting what happens is
they have this the fear of the gear this
was me I had the fear of the gear when I
got started it was so hard for me to
understand how to use cameras like this
honestly this I will be honest is still
kind of a prop
I understand it's got a cool flippy out
screen you can connect some audio to it
I don't even know what this lens is this
looks really good on my shelf that's
where I was with video had a camera had
the audio had the lens had the things
didn't make the video why fear of the
gear fear of the gear and this is where
let me know when the chat is this where
you are is gear not your thing I know
that Tony and Nolan and Omar and Sean
and even Melissa they geeked out over
this this to me is like going to college
for rocket science this looks like to me
let me know D can you relate I mean I'm
a very educated person I'm a super smart
person thank you I'm just this is
humblebrag right now okay but this right
here I know that Tony and Nolan and Sean
and Omar and Melissa had told me what
these things mean like what does this
mean I don't I don't know I don't know
but this held me back for so long
understanding that I had fear of the
gear that's what I had fear of the gear
and remember your first videos they're
gonna be your worst videos I know that
you might be having fear of the gear and
all you actually need let me go back all
you actually need really is this you
probably already have one you've
probably already spent like a thousand
dollars on some type of device that's
sitting right next to you it's probably
dinging right now too if you get our
notifications on don't have
notifications on all right so you don't
need fancy gear to make great videos I
mean we learned in session number one
that there are multiple channels right
now that have blown up to over million
subscribers with just using an iPhone
you do not need to go out and invest a
ton of money first to get a video out
let me know in the comments section
below do you already have a smartphone
do you already have a smartphone yes or
no I have a smartphone I don't have a
smartphone do you already have a camera
yes or no in the comments because
remember your first videos they're gonna
be your worst videos and I am here to
share with you that my first videos were
my worst videos here I am yesterday I
talked about you know one of the
mistakes content creators make is that
they don't look at the camera lens look
at that photo right there oh all of its
glory and fuzziness and out-of-focus and
where are my eyes not looking at the
camera
yeah first videos are gonna be your
worst videos check out that other one
I'm standing on a box why am i standing
on a box in a very cluttered office
because Sean is six too and I'm five
five so when we do a training next to
each other I look like a child so I have
to stand on a box in order to be able to
be closer to Sean's level so that's a
box from Omar's garage and you'll notice
my hands my hands are like right by my
side they're like that
because my pit stains from being so
nervous were giant and I was like if I
move my arms right now they are going to
see my pit stains this is the first time
I did a live video training and I was
like I will teach like this
I will teach like this with my arms
right here at the entire time why
because of my pit stains your first
videos they're gonna be your worst video
so just get over it you're gonna you're
it you're gonna it you're gonna sweat
it's part of the process so just know
that it's happening but here's what
people ask okay so I'm ready to make my
videos I'm excited to make my videos
what camera do I need what camera do I
need to get started and I want to share
with you because we're talking about how
do you get views how do you get watch
time well you have to understand the
gear that you're using you have to have
some knowledge in some of the gear that
you're using whether you're starting
with an iPhone whether you're using a
point-and-shoot or you're using a
full-on camera with a flippy op screen I
don't even know what it's called is it a
DSLR I don't know mirrorless I don't
know well we'll keep going and actually
there's more than just the camera it's
called AVL audio/video and lighting all
three of these together actually produce
great video you can have just a camera
that's fine but just a camera isn't
actually all that you need to be
creating great video and again the video
does matter like content is king but
it's got to be wrapped nicely in a
package you can't just throw out with
some garbage video and expect that
you're gonna get lots of views and watch
time no we are here to help you with
your learning curve we are here to help
you understand that it's more than just
the camera and again all you need to get
started is an iPhone a smartphone an
Android a five-year-old phone it does
not matter a tablet something that has a
camera on it is what I need you to use
to get started and if you want to go up
a level from there you can go up to a
nice point-and-shoot camera and what I
like about this camera here this is a
the camera on the screen is it has a
flip up screen if you're videoing by
yourself it is amazing to be able to
know what you're videoing the point
issue I have here while it's great
it doesn't actually have a flip-up
screen and for youtubers from people
creating content that's a key to know
what you're filming with and so I would
recommend a camera like this easy fits
in your pocket um you can you can shoot
you can see this is me trying to do a
camera tutorial guys this is horrible
I'm drowning Toni I'm drowning alright
so just being open and honest with you
this is just this is my level I am
interested in this and I will share all
I can about this and we will move on but
if you want to know the top camera
recommendations for any budget think
dear guy.com we've put that together for
you so that we can walk you through
depending on your budget and the type of
camera we get asked all the time what
camera should I get should I get the m50
or should I get the SL - should I use
this Nikon or should I use this and
every person's situation is slightly
different and so we've created an entire
gear guide for you to walk you through
our best recommendations for the most
common uses of a camera when creating
content for YouTube so I definitely
recommend writing that URL down think
gear guide comm and that'll help you
select your camera
but again what camera do you need the
one you already have
why do you need just the one you already
have because you need to get started if
you haven't started yet and you're
waiting for the next upgrade and you're
waiting for the things you are holding
back on the message that needs to get
out your first videos are going to be
your worst videos so let's the get them
out of the way but I'll just keep saying
that over and over and maybe you're
already creating videos and you're like
okay Heather I'm past this I understand
that I have the right camera great well
let's walk into the next piece and the
next piece is actually the lighting it's
I'm sorry the next piece is actually the
audio the audio the audio audio is
actually more important than video
quality audio is more important than
video quality write that down
because most people think that it's all
about the camera and really audio has so
my people will watch a poorly lit video
but when you can't hear when it's
scratchy when it's echoey we tune out
move on we need to hear clean audio when
we're producing content we want our
audience wants that so how do you get
more watch time have good audio and you
could do something as simple as a
microphone for $20 that can part that
can go right into your phone it can go
right into your camera very simple
investment now right here is the shirt
MB 88 that's actually the one that I am
using I'm using the shure mb 88 it comes
with this little cover on it so you can
see there that there's that one i have
this one
um and i love it because it allows you
just like that guys doing he's recording
his family or you can turn in you can
record yourself it's such a versatile
microphone for your phone there's also
very simple ones that you can use a USB
mic so here i am creating a video for
you and i'm using a webcam and i'm using
a microphone now again if I didn't have
this webcam and I was only using my
laptop camera I would still invest in
audio because audio is the key to great
video write that down audio is the key
to great video alright so we've gone
through a VL I think we should switch it
I know that that is like a term in the
industry for cool people I think it
should be v al don't you video audio
lighting but I digress I'm not the
person that came up with the statement I
know it's like a real term in the world
so we're gonna stick with it a VL now
we're gonna head into lighting heading
into lighting let me know in the
comments below what lighting do you
currently use what lighting do you use
when you're creating your videos do you
use a ring light do you use soft boxes
now here's what I love I love fr EE I
don't know about you I have all for free
I am for free beautiful lighting and how
do you get that you sit in front of a
window it's that easy how do you make
your videos look better so people watch
them longer you sit in front of a window
having great lighting right now right
now this is man I wish I could stand up
and turn off the lights but if I did
that you'd see I'm wearing sweat pants
and I don't want you to see that so the
lighting on right now is directional and
it's coming towards me it's
making my face glow are you not seeing
this beautiful glow it's happening
because of the lighting it's not I mean
it's natural but at the same time this
is a glow that's happening that is
helping to illuminate my face and we'd
love to see people lit up Hollywood as
you know is so good at great lighting
and so we're just pulling off of that to
make simple YouTube videos and you could
do that for free by just moving in front
of a window you can't also do something
very simple like this so this is that
same camera we've added a microphone on
the side and we've also added on just a
cheap twenty dollar ring light having
some type of lighting that illuminates
your face will help your video quality
so much more you can't also do something
like this this is sitting on top of a
Sony and this is just a very inexpensive
light that can really light you up so if
you're doing vlogging or if you're if
you're if someone's filming you while
you're walking this is just a light that
can help because you can't have these
big giant lights all around um this is a
great light to just have right in front
of you and we use this when we go and do
video shoots that are you know out in
the city we bring these lights because
we want to still be able to point some
direction towards the subject when we're
filming and if you want to check out
over on think media I'm actually just
the model here I did not do this video
Nolan who went to film school and has
worked on major TV productions and movie
sets he walked through how to do proper
three-point lighting so right now I have
two point lighting because I have one on
this side and one on this side and he'll
teach you about that back light and
he'll teach you about some really cool
lighting tricks that's over on think
media we'll make sure that that video
gets to you in your follow-up email for
today's training but that'll help you to
understand oh that's how you move the
lights around and we'll also include how
to do lighting if you're wearing glasses
because if you see right now I've got my
glasses on and I'm doing my best to keep
them without the the shininess of the of
the boxes but here's my soft boxes these
are the two that I use I move them
around my room
my desk is off of the wall and so I'm
able to
you had these lighting boxes just right
in front of me pointing to the side but
it's very simple remember what are we
gonna do we're just gonna start messy so
if that means your smartphone on a pile
of shoe boxes in front of a window and
that's where you're starting then that's
where I want you to start that's where I
want you to start all right now like how
do you make videos Heather okay we're
getting into that that's what we're
getting into right now because when I
asked this morning what are you what are
your struggles when it comes to making
videos is that the technical side is it
the content side and I think 80% of you
said it's the content I don't know how
to structure my videos I don't know how
to make them I don't know how to edit
them what should I do and so I want to
share with you two videos that I want
you to watch after this session we'll
make sure you get these links but I have
a quick 30 minute step-by-step tutorial
that walks you through how to do it all
on your phone how to edit it on your
phone how to record it on your phone the
right settings you should have on your
phone if you're using a phone to make
your videos and and so much more how to
do your thumbnails upload everything 30
minutes you will know how to do a video
and if you're more advanced than a phone
and you already have a beautiful camera
and a microphone and all the things and
you are already using maybe a higher end
or a desktop editing program like
Premiere Pro or now say that five times
fast Premiere Pro or Final Cut you can
walk through Sean's step-by-step
tutorial and you get behind the scenes
on exactly how he does a full video edit
from start to finish you can see how
he's filming it and he gives so many
tips and tactics on that video also how
you should upload it to YouTube and what
file size and all those things will make
sure you get that video so how do you
make a video you have to have the right
ingredients so now you know we know a V
L right let's walk through it we've
learned a VL we've learned that we need
to have the right ingredients we've
learned that there's two other videos
that you can go watch to learn step by
step how to actually do the things like
how do I edit like what is the keys and
what does it look like in Premiere and
how do I do it on my phone we've given
you that and now we're gonna walk
through our our think media content
formula this is a form that we use on
every single video how do we get to a
million views this formula how do we get
to like forum forty million views a
month this formula because we have the
right ingredients we have the right
ingredients when it comes to this and
what is the magic secret sauce is you
can use this for all types of video
whether it be training videos whether
whether you have what any niche this
works for this is a formula that you can
use on your videos and here's what it
looks like the think media content
formula you've got your hook you've got
your content and you have your CTA or
your call to action your hook your
content your CTA alright let's walk
through this we have the hook the hook
what is the hook Heather well the hook
is at the very beginning of the video
that's what you say
that's what hooks someone in to wanting
to watch the whole video so we've
already talked about you need to have a
great title because they need to be able
to discover you you should have a great
thumbnail if you've got the YouTube
starter kit you can dive into all of our
best secrets and tips for how we make
thumbnails and so we've got our title
our thumbnail now we need to make sure
that we hook them they click on it and
they need to know right away that this
is a video they need to watch and a huge
mistake that content creators make is
they open videos like this let me know
in the comments if you watched video
like this video comes on you click it
and this one they go hey guys thanks so
much for being here I know it's been so
long since I made a video I'm so sorry
and yeah like I was with my dog and it
was really fun anyways today we're gonna
talk about right have you have you heard
that you're like you wasted three
seconds of my life please don't do that
again okay so that is not what a hook is
a hook is strong if you've ever watched
a think media video you know it that
we're using a hook because you see the
topic you see the title you see the
thumbnail you click on it and then we're
like do you want to learn how to edit
videos on premiere and you're like oh my
gosh they read my mind that's exactly
what I needed I needed this video you
hook them into the content so how do you
get your click-through rate you get
someone to click by your title and your
thumbnail how do you get someone to
watch
you start with a great hook now what
does that look like for a great hook you
want to stop the scroll meaning they've
done it they've clicked on it you don't
want them to back out and keep scrolling
you want to stop the scroll you want to
grab attention you want to grab their
attention meaning you want to give them
a problem or solution you want to give
them some way of authority showing that
you know how to do this you want to show
quickly the before and after just like
Tony shared in that quick tip when he
said we are using different types of
shots to show what we're doing someone
who is interested in understanding how
to livestream would watch that videos
would watch that video in my actual
words that I'm saying I'm giving a
problem and a solution so that they know
that this is the video they need to
watch to answer their question and
what's the point of the hook the point
of the hook let me go here the point of
the hook is actually to convince the
viewer to watch the rest of the content
that's the entire point of the hook so
are you using hooks in your videos let
me know in the comments are you using
hooks in your videos and I want to give
you a little bit of swipe copy swipe
copy means you basically fill in the
blank so take this screenshot this write
this down here is one thing you will
hear a say a lot I think media and
you'll see a lot of our students in
video ranking Academy say this as well
and here's what it is
in this video I'm going to show you how
to blank blank in this video I'm gonna
show you why blank blank blank why do we
do that because we want to give them
clarity on exactly what we're teaching
so for me it would say if for my
homeschool channel in this video I in
this video I want to show you how you
could start homeschooling your kids
without having to buy any new products
that's the hook I'm telling you exactly
what I'm going to teach them it hooks
them because now they're like well I
want to know how to buy how to at home
school without buying any products that
is called the clarity hook alright
moving on to the next one the next one
is called the problem solution hook the
problem/solution hook are you struggling
with fill in the blank well in this
video I'm gonna teach you I'm gonna
share with you I want to explain how to
or why or fill in
those words but this is the problem
solution you want to identify the
problem they're having so for think
media are you struggling with getting
views on your video well in this video
I'm gonna teach you my five step process
for not only getting views but actually
increasing your subscribers at the same
time there you go that's a hook that's a
problem-solution hook now every time you
watch a think media think media video or
think marketing video you're gonna be
like oh that's the hook I see it I see
what they're doing and that's what I
want you to do because you need to
identify the problem and share how you
are going to give them the solution
alright we're moving on to the think
media formula we've talked about the
hook now we're gonna get into the
content and then we'll cover the CTA so
the content the content hacks I want for
you is here's the contacts script and
outline script and outline please write
that down and circle it and highlight it
and do all the things script and outline
why do people fail on their content they
don't know what they're talking about
so you need to go into understanding the
content with understanding what are you
going to talk about what are the three
points what do they need to know how
long do you want this video to be really
thinking about it right member prior
planning prevents poor performance so
when we are here making videos that
think media we go through a three step
process we do a title a process where we
kind of brainstorm a bunch of titles
that's one part then we script the
entire video now we don't do word for
word we decide what is the hook gonna be
we know what that's gonna be what's the
main content are we reviewing a camera
are we doing the verses are we sharing
how to do something what is the actual
meet of the content and what do they
need to know so we always put the needs
to know in there and then we also want
to know in our video when we're
scripting it what do we want the call to
action like what do we want to ask them
in the question for of the question of
the day we always want to make sure that
we're engaging our audience and so we
want to actually pre plan those before
we go into video and then we review the
scripts now if you're doing this solo
you should still review your script but
or you film your video number two you
want to number your points and steps
this is a psyche when you want to figure
out how do I get people to watch a whole
video you give them how many steps or
points or pieces of the puzzle when you
start your video so in this video I'm
gonna share with you my three-step
process
in this video I'm gonna share five hacks
in this video I want to share 21 ways
right when you number things in your
videos people 1 understand that they
need to stay cuz they want all 21 if I
if I just said I'm gonna share with you
some of the ways well you wouldn't you
would think how many some I don't know
I'm gonna share all how many is all so
you want to actually number or make
steps for your points and that'll help
you also say structured in your content
and the question we get so often here at
think media is how long should my videos
be your videos should be as long as they
need to be but they need to be as short
as possible especially when you're just
starting and again there is room for
long-form content which means videos
that are like this that are trainings
and longer form and podcasts and those
types of things but at the beginning
when you're just starting
what can hold you back is that it takes
so long to get through the video and
then it takes so long to edit the video
and then no one watches the full video
so let's make them short let's make them
punchy if you have tens ten steps you
want to share with someone make ten
videos rather than one video with ten
steps make sense so you can get through
that so much faster alright those are
the content hacks for today we have so
many more contacts that I want to share
with you but I want to get through this
material right now so we've talked about
the hook we talked about the content and
now we're on to the call to action CTA
means call to action in every single
video you want to tell people where to
go next
what is their next step this is a big
piece that people miss and when do you
need a call to action you can have it
anywhere in the video and here I think
media and when we're teaching students
how to do this we
have more than one call to action have a
call to action to the same thing more
than one time why because a lot of
people don't watch to the end of the
video but if you are the person that is
bringing people to YouTube they watch
your video and then they click on the
next one to go watch another video or
they they start going down that like
rabbit hole of binging content but
you're the one that brought them to the
video you get credit for that on your
channel so when you are doing your
videos make sure that you have multiple
call to actions and these are not spammy
this is like smash the like and
subscribe because I'm awesome
no that's we are that is we are not
those people we're not we're not doing
that okay here's what a call to action
is hey if you would like to go further
and learn more about how to X Y & Z then
make sure that you check out the next
video because I share X Y & Z that's a
call to action you could do that up in
the YouTube cards right you do cards are
always over here or in the description
below why are we doing that because we
want to help people and educate people
how they can go to the next step now if
you are a business owner which I'm
hoping that you are we want you to make
sure you're giving away free value so
what's next what's next is that you that
you give a free download that you they
can schedule a call just like we showed
Steve Panetta the real estate agent
that's in Phoenix Arizona crushing it
right now he doesn't have very many
subscribers but it's called to action is
hey if you're looking for a home in the
Phoenix area make sure to give me a call
and his phone number is right there at
the very top of that video so a call to
action is always what is the next step
in a lot of times you don't feel like
what I don't want to be spammy I don't
want to sell I don't want to you know
here's what I needs you to realize when
someone spends time with you on video
like this if they don't know what to do
next they won't do anything it's true if
you don't tell someone where they should
go next they probably will just end the
session with you find something else
won't you know if you say hey I am here
to help remember we went through those
terms last night you're you don't have
to be an expert you could be a helper a
guide a teacher a best friend
hey for me in my videos for homeschool
it would look like this if you really
liked videos just like this and you want
to learn how you can actually homeschool
your kindergartner then make sure to
check out the next video that I'm just
telling them exactly what to do next if
they have a kindergartner or here I
think media it could be it could be just
like this hey if you would like to take
a 7 day challenge on how to crush it on
YouTube and get more views and
subscribers then make sure to sign up
for our free challenge I'll put the link
down below or you can go over to tube
influence dot-com call to action I told
them where to go next
so you want to make sure you have a call
to action in every video it is vital
that someone knows where they need to go
next one of the biggest mistakes that
creators make when creating content
energy say it with me
Melissa Tony I see you say it with me
energy energy energy you have to have
energy when you're creating content if
you're sitting like this and you're just
talking to the camera and you have no
expression and you're just kind of
normal just like this that is boring no
one wants that so here's what we need to
do you need to get yourself pumped up ok
you need to get your energy up
inflection in your voice be passionate
about what you're teaching smile and
show joy come through the lens that's
what you want to have when you're
creating content why do people love
watching content creators all the way
through because they love the content
creator because they want to know the
person right and so how do you do this
with energy energy energy energy you
need energy when you're creating videos
but again remember we're just gonna
start messy I just threw so much at you
like you might have a full full page of
notes right now like okay I need to do
my hook what's my hook okay I need to
figure out my content what's my content
okay I know I need to figure out my call
to action where am I going I don't have
a download where should I do okay stop
stop stop we're gonna start messy this
is not gonna be perfect it never is
it's okay but these are just the pieces
of the recipe that we need when we're
making videos we need to understand how
do we use our gear
we need to understand what do we need we
need to understand how do we do it and
that's what we just learned so here's
what I need you to remember start with
what you have just start with what you
have if you have an iPhone I saw in the
chat people were saying it I've got a
phone I could start with the phone
that's where you need to start that's
where you need to start it may not be
the best video of your life I hope it
probably isn't
because video number 1000 is gonna be so
much better than video number one but
you cannot get to video 1000 until you
make video number what I'm talking to
you right now the person who has not
made the video the person who is writing
down all the notes but it still has not
pressed record I'm talking to you I'm
talking to you right now if you've made
videos and you're discouraged because
you're like no one likes this and what
you're actually thinking is no one likes
me and I want to encourage you you have
to start with what you have you have to
start with what you have you will not
get to video 1000 until you do video
number one so let's crush video number
one let's crush video number 100 let's
crunch video number 500 so we can get to
video 1000 so we can actually be making
an impact in a difference in the world
so you ready I'm ready are you ready to
make a video I'm ready to make videos
make it a video right now right this
second we're making a video all right
this is gonna be what we're doing but
hold on hold on okay so you're like
great okay committed making your video
let's do it
this is where yesterday's enemies will
start to come up again
what's enemy number one perfectionism
that's what's gonna be number one I
guarantee most people this is the number
one enemy well I can't do it I was right
lighting I can't do it I don't have the
thing I don't have that no we're not
doing that
we're busting through excuses today
we're making a new video today that's
what we're doing we're here on this
challenge to make videos but here's what
it's going to look like it's gonna look
like this start with the box what's the
box
the
box is that content formula I am not
asking for more than what I just gave
you I want you to have the hook I want
you to have the content think it through
know what you're doing make sure you
don't make those seven mistakes and then
give a call to action and this is all
I'm asking I want you to make a basic
cupcake I'm not asking for a full cake
I'm not asking for the unicorn cake I
want you to make a cupcake this could be
you actually creating your first YouTube
videos this could be maybe a step before
that and you just making an Instagram
video this could be you actually have
already been creating videos but you
need to just level it up this is what
I'm asking for you today
and then the next video we're gonna put
some frosting and sprinkles on it yeah
we're gonna use these really cute tin
cups rather than these ugly brown like
who who is the person that decided that
we needed
ugly white ones hello we need pretty
confetti ones that's what we need
that's what cupcakes need and then as we
go through we get to maybe video 30
maybe video 100 and we're gonna be
making a cake we're gonna do two layers
with some frosting and it's gonna look
so pretty set up for Pinterest that's
what we're gonna do this is maybe you've
upgraded your lighting maybe this is you
finally got the big camera maybe this is
you you you got a whole studio you
decided that you are going all in you're
creating a full studio space to create
your YouTube videos maybe that's what
this is and then eventually over time
we're gonna get here eventually over
time you're all in on YouTube eventually
over time people are watching your
videos millions of people a month are
watching your videos
that's what we're gonna get to how do we
increase watch time how do we increase
people watching your videos you have to
understand the basics of making videos
and I want you to just strive to get one
percent better every time that's all I'm
asking one percent better every time now
here's what happens to me it'll take me
30 minutes to set up I'll do my tests
and I'm like shoot I messed that up or I
walk through my content and I'm and I
have to restart five times because I
keep four
what the last point is or I get to the
editing phase and I'm like oh my gosh
why do I sound like that
anyone else every time I make a video
I'm like why can't I just sound normal
whatever normal is that's what in my
mind I think I want to sound like but we
want to just get 1% better and this is
your time remember we're going all-in
we're doing YouTube maybe you've already
made some videos maybe you're already
committed I want you to recommit we're
making videos how do you give views on
YouTube you make youtube videos how do
you increase those you get 1% better
every single time it's vital it's vital
that we do that Wow well I really hope
that that inspired you to start creating
videos you know and you have the
framework when you know the mistakes
it's so important that you start to
apply that and I want to challenge you
to take action I think there's nothing
better than starting messy and just
starting to get those videos out there
and I want to also say thank you so much
for being a part of this community you
know our community here at think
marketing has really grown and your
feedback has been so vital to knowing
what type of podcasts you want to hear
and so thank you so much for leaving
comments over on YouTube and we would
ask you if you like this type of content
to go over to iTunes and rate and review
us tell other people what you love about
the think marketing show and other
pieces of content you would like us to
cover here we are always listening we're
always there reading through those
reviews and also the comments over on
the think marketing show on YouTube so
make sure you subscribe over there and
again this is the time to take action
and the best way to do that is to grab
that camera grab whatever you have and
start recording videos because we know
here at think media that possibilities
are after you take the first step so
thank you so much for watching or
listening and I'll catch you in the next
so